hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we have a teaser of the new
character for season 11 whatever his
name happens to be we just have a small
image that we can kind of look at and
delve deep into what this character may
look like obviously we don't have
everything the move set the execution
and all that stuff but we'll be getting
that next week but we're gonna be
talking about that in a little bit it
was always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe before new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the Patrick's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out when an
update definitely say subscribe the
channel and let's get started with
today's video so next week like I said
we have the exciting stream of the new
character there's also going to be a
double xp weekend as well this week so
if you want to rank up any new
characters or any current characters
that may be in your roster definitely go
do that this weekend it's gonna be a
hell of a lot of fun and on top of that
I plan on streaming tomorrow which is
going to be Friday
I plan on streaming Friday and Sunday we
ground some double xp and I also got
access to a technical test of a new game
coming soon that you may or may not know
if you play on xbox so there's a little
tease of what that is if you know you
know but yeah we're gonna be playing it
roughly both those games this weekend
probably in a couple streams or so so
come by if you want I'm very excited to
be playing that new game as well as be
grounded double xp for any new
characters and stuff like that so
definitely come by if you want and the
thing that you've all been waiting for
we have the new character image as a
teaser here's the picture of our new
character coming to for honor there's no
confirmation on the man's name but this
dude looks [ __ ] insane as you can see
by some rocks it's on the stormy night
thus implying the whole water picture
that we saw on the roadmap but this dude
just from the picture has lots of crazy
leather around him with some bones as
well surrounding his neck so this dude
definitely does not [ __ ] around there's
still no confirmation whether he's gonna
be wielding the hammer two-handed
one-handed or combination of both I'm
really hoping that it's a there going to
be a combination kind of like hito kiri
or with a two-handed I'd be totally down
for that so that will come next week
along with everything else like as
moveset executions and probably some
armor as well and he'll maybe even the
new rework for season 11 won't be in
that stream too I really hope so let me
know in the comments below what you guys
think is going to be happening for the
reworks I personally think it's going to
be gladiator and Centurion well let me
know what you guys think of the comments
below yeah like I said very excited for
this new
hopefully next week we're gonna be
getting lots of more info on this guy
maybe some more judging by the picture
we're most like its most likely going to
be identified with the male version like
how with black prior we usually called
him from the male version of vortac err
we usually called hito kiri Sakura cuz
that was the female name were most
likely gonna be calling this guy the
male name of whatever it happens to be
so I'll be excited cuz remember for this
season and the season after this it's
going to be male and female so not only
are we getting a giant-ass dude with a
big-ass hammer we're also going to be
getting a giant-ass female that also
doesn't [ __ ] around with a big-ass
hammer so it's equally going to be as
fun for me you guys are any lower
experts in Viking lore I know a lot of
you guys are super big into the medieval
style and all these types of factions if
you guys can give some other info that I
may or may not know about this character
maybe you can already figure out what
the name will be just judging based off
the picture because I know a lot of
people were coming up with the name of
the character hito kiri before she
released him why not so if you guys have
any info like that that I would love for
you to share that and I'll hopefully be
making a video on that before they're
released and on top of that we also
don't have the trailer just yet but
hopefully that trailer will be releasing
in the next couple days before the
reveal stream so when that does I would
definitely be sure to post a video on
that we're gonna be looking at all the
juicy stuff this character comes from
assuming he does have a trailer yeah
guys it's gonna be the end of the video
hopefully guys did enjoy it like I said
leaving the comments down below what you
guys think are gonna be the new reworks
for season 11 who you want to have a
rework or anything that you want to talk
about with the new character whether he
looks cool looks garbage or any other
lore bits that you may try to piece
together if you're kind of an expert in
that field
yeah like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the petrol stand the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe the
channel and with that guys have a great
Esther day peace out and hopefully I'll
be seeing you a couple days when the
trailer does release
[Music]
you
[Music]